[Music]
you don't know everything about me
The Avengers weren't my first family at
some point we all have to choose between
what the world wants you to be
new your nope
secret finds its way out there'll be the
death of him this was your choice
Ronnie we got some kind of fire we got
units headed out there now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna burn this place to the ground
clothes organics six of our northern
cities have fallen in a coordinated
attack their leader fights alongside of
which
crush these murderers your majesty every
family must contribute one mob to fight
your war hero you've already made many
great sacrifices my father cannot fight
so I will take his place the northern
invaders will kill her if I expose her
power all people will kill her when we
take the Imperial City I will take
revenge for my father what is your name
soldier
watch it commander so no quarrels you
will now take the oath of the warrior
wait
release
[Music]
by pretending to be something you're not
yet here I stand proof that there is a
place for people like us
a girl threatens our place
a warrior
[Applause]
[Music]
when it comes to speed there's only one
name I've studied the best spinners his
legendary I raced the fastest in the
world he makes us all its left I'm wild
but he's on another level that dude he
knows it's all about the Rings he turns
on the burners good luck
he's just a blur out there what's this
for again what's this for gets this
Morgan what's this for again great
question I have no idea but please
McCaffrey go on about how amazing I am
what am i doing
now that's what I call good cop bad cop
left herself open the commercials in
this game are really expensive spongebob
it's just the pregame yeah 26 seconds to
tell me everything the only thing
missing is Gary
[Music]
let's go do I smell a roadtrip there
could be my breath the spongebob movie
sponge on the run that was money well
spent
[Music]